we begin this morning with more history
unfolding in Washington for just the
third time in this nation's history the
House of Representatives will vote on
whether to impeach a president next
week's decision follows Friday's
fiercely divided party line vote by the
House Judiciary Committee approving two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump the president fired back
at Democrats insisting he has done
nothing wrong
he called the hearings a hoax and a sham
and claimed the tool of impeachment is
being misused Paula Reid is at the White
House with more Paula good morning good
morning Dana those articles of
impeachment will head to the full house
next week for a vote and then on to a
likely Senate trial and CBS News has
learned that the president's top lawyer
and his top legislative aide will
continue to meet with the Republican
senators this week to figure out what
exactly that trial should look like
they're trying to balance the
president's desire for a big show with
the GOP leadership theory that when it
comes to the president's defense less is
more following Thursday's 14 hours of
acrimonious debate the House Judiciary
Committee on Friday sent two articles of
impeachment to the full house with a
vote scheduled for next week mr.
chairman there are 23 eyes and 17 nose
your article is agreed to the partisan
ranker continued after the vote I have a
tremendous amount of faith in the
American people and I would just say
look past the Republicans obstruction
and live for Democrats impeachment is
their drug it is their obsession it's a
scam and President Trump
unloaded in a White House photo op with
the leader of Paraguay you're
trivializing impeachment and I tell you
what someday there'll be a Democrat
president and there'll be a Republican
House and I suspect they're gonna
remember it Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell who is rankled Democrats by
coordinating with the White House over
our likely Senate trial insists the
president will not be removed from
office and says he wants this done
quickly the house the only thing
bipartisan maybe the opposition
to the two articles of impeachment
nevertheless we will have an impeachment
problem just before the Judiciary
Committee vote mr. Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani was seen entering
the White House where he stayed for two
hours
Giuliani told CBS News that he would be
willing to participate in a Senate trial
adding if they want a lesson in
cross-examination they should have me do
it Giuliani says that he communicates
with the president constantly despite
the fact that he is at the center of the
events that led to impeachment and he's
currently under investigation by the
Trump Justice Department Giuliani
insists he did not break any laws and
while he is not expected to be part of a
Senate trial he says he would
participate if asked Michele all right
Paula thank you